hey guys I'm just it is Thursday and
here's all the things that mattered in
videogames today
[Music]
first up persona 5 the game that had me
making lockpicks all day Sunday and
buying 50 band-aids off the Home
Shopping Network has sold a ton of
copies developer atlas announced that
persona 5 has shipped 1.5 million copies
worldwide
the game launched for ps3 and ps4 in
September of last year in Japan and
arrived in the West earlier this week
there's currently no word on how that
figure compared to previous games in the
series in other persona e-news Atlas
announced super-strict streaming
policies that threaten people who show
off too much of the game's story the
Playstations sharing features are also
blocked while playing the game so I
guess you'll just have to keep your
hashtag relatable screenshots to
yourself I'll post them on Twitter with
your folks
next up state of decay 2 is getting
three open worlds Maps at launch with
more potentially on the way developer
undead lab said in a blog post that each
of the three launch maps will be roughly
the size of the original the dev added
you should expect to see slightly
different environments definitely
different landmarks and locations
different layouts lending themselves to
different strategies unique home sites
and even different mission types as for
why there are three Maps the studio said
they didn't want players to experience a
sense of déjà vu and they liked the idea
of it feeling like you're moving from
one small town to another they added
that the multi map setup will make it
easier to expand the world later down
the line and add implied you'll be able
to take all of the survivors and every
item collected on one area to the others
and you'll get a refund on buildings you
create in one area when you move on of
course being that the game is still in
development all of that is subject to
change state of decay 2 is due out this
year on Xbox one and PC finally
Microsoft have dropped the tech specs
for their fancy new upgraded Xbox one
project Scorpio digital foundry reported
that Scorpio could run a flotsam
motorsport demo at 60 frames per second
in seemingly native 4k with graphical
settings at an
oops one equivalent level digital
foundry called Scorpios GPU a beast as
at 4.6 times as powerful as the Xbox one
and says the console will run all Xbox
one games better regardless of if
they're patched for the new console
combined with the fast CPU which has
eight custom x86 cores clocked at 2.3
gigahertz compared to ps4 pro's 2.1
gigahertz and increased memory bandwidth
326 gigabytes to ps4 pros 218 the result
is a higher framerate and more stability
and faster load times the console
includes a one terabyte hard drive and
12 gigabytes of gddr5 memory
for comparison's sake the ps4 has the
same type of RAM but only eight
gigabytes digital foundry and Eurogamer
has estimated project Scorpio will cost
500 bucks but Microsoft to get to
officially announced a price for all the
nitty-gritty tech bits and pieces check
back to our story on site that's
everything I got P today do leave me
your thoughts on today's stories down in
that comment section be sure to pop back
same time tomorrow for our top 5 stories
of the entire week hit that subscribe
button if you liked today's video and
I'll see you tomorrow